it is a seminar which is organized by
the Council the Council of the
European Union and by the Publications Office
which brings together in its
executive committee all the
European institutions we are gathered to
talk about a subject which is not new
in general but which is a little
new for the institutions the
electronic books eBox and we wanted to
invite colleagues from other
large institutions the nations unite the
World Bank the OECD the NATO which
finds itself confronted with the same problem
as large national institutions
how to disseminate how to move from the
paper world to the digital world
ofat
the editions of CDE in fact have moved to
electronic mode it is more than 10 years old and
in fact today already 90% of
dissemination 9% our ch of  business
is generated by online publishing so
in fact the challenge today is
to continue to innovate and to continue
to bring new services to
users through of course as
everyone knows the new
media the new  dev in
fact
you and we are now progively also seeing
that we can promote all our content in
online media including EBS so that's the
future